[Music]
you
a vain and uncouth humor listen doll I
pity any woman who confuses the buzz of
a martini with your chores
[Music]
mastery
what did you do
I made all your dreams come true
I look like Bruce Wayne
you'll make me Bruce Wayne
so my rich handsome love it
Bruce I need you to strut through the
doors of Wayne tower and get me that
shard of kryptonite from your dear
cousin the gate
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Batman video for the
arrowverse we just found what Batman
looks like inside earth prime on all
these shows it's pretty crazy so we'll
break it down there's a bunch of Easter
eggs for crisis on Infinite Earths and
there's a bunch of big news about one of
the major arrowverse leads just quitting
their show after the first season so
I'll explain that during the video too
because it is crazy if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post all your
theories about Batman on earth prime so
just starting with this post credit
scene this is Thomas Eliot hush on earth
prime in the arrow verse who just got
Bruce Wayne's face and his voice so this
actor is effectively the real main
Batman in the arrow verse now this is
what he'll look like when he shows up
we've already seen several versions of
Batman during crisis on Infinite Earths
and previously on the shows and if you
consider the multiverse scenes and
post-credit scene that tie all the other
DC series from DC universe to the arrow
verse and the Justice League movie that
DC EU movies there are even more
versions of Batman that we have inside
the arrow verse so I'll break all them
down - and what this means for Batman in
the future of the TV shows within the
context of the flash the new Superman
series and all the other shows in
present day we had been told that about
four years ago from present day from
crisis on Infinite Earths Batman left
their version of Gotham never to be
heard from again he's still missing post
rebirth if you consider all of her
rebooting the multiverse during crisis
on Infinite Earths to be a version or a
big Easter Egg for DC rebirth so that's
kind of what he did the funny thing
about this actor playing Batman Bruce
Wayne is that he actually starred on
arrow during season 1 so he's already
been inside the arrow verse so you can
look at that anyway you want to treat it
to some weird Easter Egg maybe they'll
have a funny joke about it in a future
season but the character he played was
during arrow season 1 his name was
Carter Bowen so he wasn't like a major
other character it's not like Chris
Evans going from being Johnny Storm in
the Fantastic Four Fox movies to being
Captain America in the MCU it's not
quite that big but within the arrowverse
within Earth Prime the earliest we knew
him to be active his Batman was 2003 /
his
backstory because that's when he was
chasing the Joker who had stolen a
school bus Dark Knight Easter egg in bat
woman's car with her sister was driven
off the road Batman had to abandon
pursuit of the Joker to save them
so because Thomas Eliot hush is meant to
be about the same age as Bruce Wayne
inside the comics we can guess based on
his age here being in the early 40s that
Batman became Batman inside the
arrowverse on earth prime around 2000 to
2002 a lot of you will notice that that
actually puts him on par with Christian
Bale's Batman because during Batman
Begins if you're looking at that
timeline it's around 2000 to 2003 when
it comes back to Gotham to dawn the cape
and cowl the other big Easter Egg for a
Christian Bale's Batman inside the arrow
verse is that when they filmed all the
original Gotham scenes for the
arrowverse crossover two years ago it
was in Chicago which is where they shot
the Dark Knight trilogy so that's why
all the architecture from their Gotham
on earth Prime looks just like Christian
Bale's Gotham but when they use Batman
stuff inside the arrowverse they use
references for all the versions of
Batman all the movies and all the Batman
TV shows going back to Adam West's
Batman but just to be clear he's meant
to be the closest parallel of Christian
Bale's Batman so right now in all the
shows this is just hush Thomas Eliot
pretending to be Batman the real Batman
is still missing in the wild somewhere
on earth Prime it seems like they're
doing this big twist now though to
foreshadow his eventual return because
when he does show up it's basically
gonna be this actor playing the exact
same character we'll see what the
network lets them do with Batman because
the network is really hardcore about
what the TV shows are allowed to do with
the Batman character Robert Pattinson
Batman movie is coming out October 2021
next year usually that means that
there's an embargo on Batman if you
remember way back when they did
Smallville Smallville was originally
going to be the Batman show and it was
gonna be him growing up to eventually
become Batman the biggest reason why we
didn't see Bruce Wayne or Batman show up
on Smallville because that would have
been an easy slam-dunk is because when
that show was still on
they were ramping up to make Christopher
Nolan's Batman Begins and Christopher
Nolan's specifically told Warner
Brothers please don't do any other
versions of Batman on any TV shows or
any other movies while I'm doing my
version of Batman that's why the Gotham
TV show didn't come out too
2013 the year after the Dark Knight
Rises because Christopher Nolan laid
down the law he's like there shall be no
other versions of Batman but mine while
I'm making all these movies here's the
thing though we got Batman during Titan
season 1 and season 2 they confirmed
that he's coming back Batman is coming
back to Titan season 3 and if you
consider that to be connected to the
arrowverse via the multiverse we only
really saw him in the Batman suit for a
couple scenes but this is what his
Batman suit looks like he's played by
Ian Glenn from Game of Thrones Sir Jorah
Batman much older than this new earth
Prime Batman though we also have the
Kingdom Come Batman from crisis on
Infinite Earths played by Kevin Conroy
he was also kind of meant to be a
reference to Batman Beyond the eighties
something really old version of Bruce
Wayne here's the crazy thing about that
now though because we know that Batman
is in his early 40s in the arrowverse
Batwoman recognized Kevin Conroy as
Batman as Bruce Wayne so based on all
the information that they've given us
all the Easter eggs in the way they're
logically laying this young version of
Batman out the early forty-something
Batman is that when he grows up and he
gets really old he's just gonna look
like Kevin Conroy it's the same version
of Batman just one is way older
otherwise Batwoman wouldn't have
recognized him during crisis on Infinite
Earths like who are you old man why are
you inside Wayne Manor where's my cousin
Bruce Wayne either way when you go back
and you watch old episodes of arrow or
the flash now or the other shows and
they reference Batman now we know what
he's supposed to look like he's supposed
to look like this guy right here the
Batman's an urban legend wait you don't
believe Batman's real he's an urban
legend concocted by the Gotham police
department to scare criminals that
doesn't guarantee that they're gonna be
able to do more Batman on the shows or
even Batman wearing a Batman suit but
Bruce Wayne probably for sure if they
can do Bruce Wayne on Titans they can
probably do them in the arrowverse
eventually maybe not till after a Robert
Pattinson is Batman movie comes out next
year though but the other huge news
obviously talking about recent
arrowverse news is that the bomb that
just dropped on Twitter is Ruby Rose
just quit bat woman seriously just
straight up no joke when full Sponge Bob
meme I am out of here
the statement from the network says that
they're going to recast Batwoman for
season two and they are going to do
Batwoman
season two because they also just
announced that next year's big
arrowverse crossover is going to be a
big Superman Batman twist with the
Batwoman character but now apparently
it's going to be a different actress
playing that Batwoman character when
they do crossover but if you've been
watching TV for the last 10 or 15 years
you've probably seen a lot of shows try
to recast a main character and usually
they don't succeed after recasting the
mains so if the bow woman TV show was
already getting pretty low ratings on TV
recasting a new actor is probably gonna
eventually kill it long term so don't be
surprised if they do wind up cancelling
that woman after season 2 or season 3
they'll probably try to limp to at least
50 episodes so they can make some money
off the show and some partial
syndication deals and streaming deals
and if they always wanted to use those
characters they can on the other shows
so if there were any characters from
that show that you like obviously we
have an arrow versus Batman now he can
always show up on the Superman TV show
or the flash or any of the other shows
during crossovers so don't worry about
it that much but it is still crazy that
she quit after one season the
scuttlebutt is most people believe it's
because she's primarily a film actress
and just wasn't able to handle the super
long hours and time commitment during
the year because they filmed those
series for about nine months of the year
Grant Gustin said that because they do
stuff like that he hasn't been able to
do any big movies so they try to make
the show's go for like seven seasons
that's like going seven years without
doing any really huge movies which is a
huge deal for someone that considers
themselves a film actor primarily so
most people feel like she saw that down
the road and was like you know what I
don't want to do that I'm just gonna bow
out right now so I can go do movies
again I've already done a big video
about what's going on with the rest of
the arrowverse in the flash and all that
stuff next season so I'll link that
video at the end of this but post all
your reactions in the comments below
while you wait for everything click here
for my brand new Batman video and learn
about all of next year's shows and click
here for the flash season 7 teaser thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you